and chrome is gonna be upset with me I'm
sure when I say this but I think a
philosophical approach to it is it's
kind of kind of misses a lot of the
detail and it's all about the detail one
of the phenomena that I've noticed is a
politician you know knocking on doors
and talking to people is that in many
instances it's the first-generation
immigrants who look very new look very
different who want to keep out other
other immigrants because they want to
feel part of the of the host community
if you yeah
say I mean one instance you know polish
plumber a friend of mine he got his
British part passport just about three
months before the brexit vote and you
know what's coming up he was gonna vote
I asked him what he's gonna vote for he
said I'm gonna vote for brexit
absolutely a third of British Asians
yeah but his reason for brexit was very
specific I said so why are you voting
with brexit he said look I've just got
my British citizenship I don't want a
Romanian plumber to undercut my job and
that was the that was the that was the
wide spread so he feels part of the host
community and wants to protect his
privileged status within it another case
in my own constituency in Spelthorne an
Egyptian family and I was speaking to
the man he was elderly he was in his 70s
and he said well the problem is there
are too many people from the Middle East
coming into Britain and I said but
you've come from the Middle East you
come from Egypt he said yeah I came to
get away from them
I mean that's what he did that's what he
that I mean okay that's a flippant
that's a flippant but but it but it
shows it illustrates you know how
complex a lot of these these issues are
I mean they want to feel British and and
and they they don't see themselves as
being part of you know the migrant wave
if you see I mean that is true to the
extent the phenomenon I definitely seen
as well and my experience and but just
take two recent example you know the
Windrush scandal has shown that even
people who have been here 40 50 60 years
who were born like my parents and I
my grandparents under British Dominion
are still somehow psychologically within
the home office regarded as people who
maybe not brothers right well that was
well that's what exactly what school
caused the outrage that's exactly what
that's exactly why it was so appalling I
mean what was extraordinary was I mean
people forget about the BMP and the
National Front and that but the BMV
actually had a line on the wind rush
scandal and the BMV line was that they
should the government should pay to
deport these people and that was
actually a classic kind of
anti-immigration like what was
extraordinary about that the responses
to that debate was that even everyone
from the Daily Mail to the Guardian you
know right across the political piece
excluding the far-right and now I'm that
many far-right genuinely far-right
people these days I don't I would
contend everyone thought it was
outrageous that the Windrush generation
were treated in the way that it wasn't I
I mean even though the scandal was
appalling
I was quite heartened by that nobody
publicly was saying well actually they
should leave because they're not British
whereas if it had happened 30 years ago
in the 70s that would have been a much
wider a much more widely held view so in
a way although it highlighted real
problems with the government machine and
I accept that
it actually showed also how British
society had moved in the last 30 or 40
years but you were talking earlier and
you mentioned - that actually the the
the anti-immigrant sentiment is often
most fervent in places where there
aren't many immigrants so it's more a
sort of imagination a sort of imagined
community that is not part of that it's
not being extended far enough and the
thing is politicians reactions often
then is to respond to those people by
saying well you know you're going to
vote for us so we need to sort of
satisfy by being a bit harsher on
immigration even but if that isn't
actually the problem if it's a sort of
economic problem or whatever then surely
it creates the environment for kind of
Windrush scandal I think you're right
but but again I mean the extent to which
in politics perception is reality it's
something that should never be under
estimated so when people perceive things
you know the politician who says you
know you're completely deluded you don't
know what you're talking about I would
contend it's not going to be very
successful at the ballot box so you have
to you have to in a way respond to the
concerns and then you may have to say
well you know this is what we can do
it's a brave politician who says
actually you're completely deluded
because actually in many instances there
is a grain of truth in what they're
saying so and the phenomenon that you
described where communities without
immigrants complain a lot about it I
mean that's that's been observable since
the 60s remember Michael Heseltine he
was an MP down in in Tavistock which is
in the West Country it's in Dorset Devon
Devon it's in Devon my geography is
shaky
but no it was in Devon easy either he
was elected I think in 66 and he said
immigration was an issue there and he
would say well there isn't an immigrant
for 250 miles but they would still raise
it on the doorstep as an issue so I mean
you can you can laugh at that but at the
same time that's still a concern and as
a politician you do have to respond to
that